[Music]
big brothers little children stuffed
bears bullies come in all shapes and
sizes from top gun to harry potter these
are the biggest movie jerks of all time
most movie jerks are at least usually
confined to a single character but when
you bring a delorean that can traverse
time itself into the equation things get
a whole lot more complex whether it's
1955 or 1985 the character of biff
tannin is the typical bully terrorizing
everyone who gets in his way with a
horde of lackeys at his side a violent
womanizing scumbag biff nearly manages
to undo marty mcfly's very existence in
the first back to the future film things
take an especially dark turn though
after marty and doc take a trip to the
far future of 2015 when marty recklessly
picks up a sports almanac detailing the
results of every major sporting event
for the past 50 years it winds up in
biff's hands who goes back in time to
make his past self unfathomably rich he
uses his vast well to create a dystopian
reality in which he's the sole ruler of
hill valley even revealing to marty that
he killed his father some years prior
while marty and doc are able to fix the
timeline and undo biff's reign of terror
it just goes to show that across every
conceivable timeline biff is an
undeniable jerk now why don't you make
like a tree and get out of here while he
isn't the only bully from the world of
witchcraft and wizardry draco malfoy
managed to be one of the most
persistently annoying characters
throughout the entire harry potter
franchise while his antics were innocent
enough during the first few films he
went down a truly dark path over the
events of the eight films belonging to
the slytherin house draco was
practically doomed to be a bad apple
from before he even set foot in hogwarts
the malfoy family's belief that only
those of pure blood should continue the
practice of wizardry rubbed off on young
draco and it became a prejudice he would
carry for much of his life as a battle
of hogwarts approach draco would find
himself fully believing in the mission
of the death eaters becoming one himself
even though he started have a change of
heart towards the end by that point it
was too little too late as he still
played a part in the death of dumbledore
even though he wasn't always the worst
you can't deny draco was one of the most
enduring jerks in the harry potter story
the first feature film to have the
distinction of being entirely computer
animated toy story is an impressive feat
of artistry for the time that it came
out it's also a compelling story that
has endured an audience's heart since
its 1995 release focused on the life of
a group of sentient toys led by the
sheriff woody the entire status quo was
shaken when a new toy buzz lightyear is
unwrapped on their owner's birthday as
the two feud get lost and are
subsequently found by the next door
neighbor sid things can't get that bad
right well when the kid next door is a
sadistic maniac who tears toys apart and
puts them back together things can get
pretty awful between strapping a rocket
to buzz burning a hole in woody's head
and keeping an aggressive dog roaming
the halls ready to tear the duo limb
from limb since behavior made for a toys
living nightmare thankfully woody and
buzz were able to rally sid's other toys
together and teach the kid a lesson
while also probably giving him more than
a few nightmares to boot
so play nice
while john hammond's rationale to open a
park featuring giant carnivorous
dinosaurs is definitely questionable
you'd be hard-pressed to find anyone who
could really call his kind-hearted
character a jerk the sloppy
self-centered computer scientist dennis
nedry on the other hand is pretty much
universally hated by everyone who
enjoyed this spielberg classic nedry's
own greed winds up being the catalyst
for the park's destruction after he
accepts a bribe to sneak out a number of
dino embryos he disables the park's
security using it as cover to carry out
his theft it ultimately ends up biting
him though when his own reckless actions
pin him against the hostile dilaposaurus
and he meets an unsavory demise his
stupidity isn't just confined to getting
himself killed though as pretty much the
entire failure of the park as well as
its subsequent deaths can be pinned on
this self-serving jerk
focused on the day-to-day doldrums and
the insanity that results from a 95 job
office space has become an iconic movie
since its 1999 release for everything it
had to say about the american office
lifestyle at the heart of it all is bill
lumberg the division vice president of
the innotech software company and the
embodiment of your typical office drone
another cog in the machine his incessant
pestering of every employee of the
company perfectly encapsulates the
soul-crushing nature of a job we're all
too familiar with the monotone delivery
of every asinine order he gives only
further drives his employees away from
him i'm going to have to go ahead and
sort of disagree with you there the most
visible example is peter's complete
disregard for office etiquette and
protocol throughout the film as a result
of lumber's nagging the most dramatic
reaction though comes at the climax of
the film after repeatedly having the
stapler stolen and his cubicle relocated
milton makes good on his promise to burn
the office to the ground as revenge
hitting theaters in 1986 this sarcastic
coming of age comedy was a huge hit upon
release grossing over 10 times its
budget it has since gone on to be
immortalized in the hearts of everyone
who's given this classic comedy a try
with its free-spirited message a normal
teen comedy would rely on the authority
figure to be the one stifling everyone's
fun which principal ed rooney does
throughout the film but surprisingly the
worst offender to the friend group winds
up being ferris bueller himself to be
fair almost everyone who's been to high
school has likely lied to get out of
class at least once but ferris doesn't
stop at just truancy he convinces his
best friend cameron into letting them
take his father's ferrari for joyride
around chicago and probably then
backburners him to spend time with his
girlfriend ferris isn't the one who
straight up kicks the prized car through
a glass window at the end of the film
but if he had just been a little more
considerate to his friends none of that
would have ever happened
after his success in risky business and
legend tom cruise became the star of 80s
action classic top gun playing a naval
fighter pilot who goes by the callsign
maverick the macho personalities and
unending bravado needed to be a fighter
pilot or on full display throughout the
events of the film no one has a greater
sense of confidence than iceman the top
student at the top gun naval fighters
weapons school while iceman might be
justified in some of his actions in the
movie it doesn't change the fact that
his smug self-satisfaction kind of makes
everyone hate his guts the fact that he
tends to be right most of the time just
makes him even more dislikable the
majority of the jerks on this list never
find themselves getting any kind of
redemption arc with those they've
wronged but top gun bucks the trend with
both maverick and iceman seeing eye to
eye by the end of the film
sure kevin might be the main character
of this iconic 1990 comedy and sure he
was justified in defending his home from
an attempted burglary still it doesn't
make his treatment of the two thieves
that tried to break in any less sadistic
and while his older brother buzz
mcallister was a bully at least he
didn't gamble with an attempted murder
charge on a couple of lowlife crooks
whether he was setting fires leaving
nails on stairs or hurling paint cans at
the wet bandit's heads kevin definitely
crossed the line on what's acceptable
self-defense more than a few times he
never even looks all that scared even
when harry and marv are inside the
family house instead he derives some
sick pleasure from watching the pair
fall victim to another one of his traps
when he finds himself once again being
pursued by the bandits in new york city
he launches bricks at harry and even
winds up electrocuting him at one point
now he didn't get anyone killed with all
his violence as a mystery
adapted from the classic children's
novel willy wonka and the chocolate
factory has become a cinema classic
since its release the beloved gene
wilder would steal the show his
character willy wonka took a group of
children each with their own distinct
personalities down a rabbit hole of the
bizarre in this 1971 film now every kid
who was invited to willy wonka's surreal
factory was at least a bit of a brat in
their own way with even charlie bucket
being coursed into stealing one of
wonka's many wonders however it's none
other than baruch assault that has the
unenviable title a biggest jerk in the
cinema classic her constant whining and
youthful snobbery helped make her a
detestable character from the start
eventually it all comes to a head when
she's deservedly thrown down a garbage
chute in wonka's golden egg room
now a timeless classic in its genre the
1984 comedy ghostbusters is well known
for having just about each and every one
of its characters being a jerk in their
own right peter venkman himself almost
takes the title for the worst in this
film with his lust for money being his
biggest motivator in life however he's
edged out by walter pack the epa
inspector with a grudge against venkman
starting almost the second they meet you
can have it your way mr venkman
after he sees a containment device a
group is using to house a captured
spirits and is rebuked by bankman peck
returns with the law on hand his own
arrogance and distrust for the
ghostbusters lead him to order the
containment unit be shut off this is
much to the dismay of the paranormal
exterminators and even the electrician
peck brought along with him the
resulting explosion unleashes a
maelstrom of ghosts upon manhattan with
the blame resting squarely at peck's
feet
tearing apart old toys you don't even
know are alive is one thing but
sentencing the entire cast of characters
we've all grown to love for over two
decades to a fiery death is another
thing entirely lotso hugging bear or
lotso for short tricked woody buzz and
the rest of the gang at first with his
endearing personality but it didn't take
long for this deceptive bear to pull the
rug out from under our heroes with his
dictator-like style of leadership after
attempting to let buzz into his inner
circle at the daycare lotso refuses
buzz's insistence that his friends be
allowed to come with him things quickly
take a turn for the worse as lotso shows
his darker side by resetting buzz's
memory and turning him into just another
one of his minions as the plot
progresses and the rest of the toys
attempt to escape the prison like
daycare they find themselves headed
straight for a garbage incinerator
alongside the bright pink bear even
though they push him to safety lotso
refuses to return the favor effectively
dooming the group to a fiery death
before they're saved at the last second
while some of his actions might be less
evil than the majority of jerks on our
list you'll be hard-pressed to find many
characters whose names are synonymous
with being a buzzkill first appearing in
the 1966 animated film have a grinch
stole christmas this yuletide menace has
terrorized the christmas spirit for over
50 years actors such as boris karloff
jim carrey and even benedict cumberbatch
all lending their talent to bring this
mischievous character to life created by
the beloved children's author dr seuss
the character of the grinch is a
mean-spirited and cynical creature who
despises nothing more than the merriment
and festivities of christmas every
rendition of the now classic story sees
him living atop a nearby mountain while
doing everything in his power to ruin
the holiday cheer for the residents
below in midfield his plans reach a
climax as he gathers every present and
piece of christmas cheer he can find on
christmas eve with the intent to destroy
it before having a change of hearts at
the last second come christmas morning
while most retellings of this timeless
story over the years had been animated
jim carrey's live-action version in 2000
was memorable to say the least
in what's arguably one of comedian and
actor adam sandler's best films to date
this 1996 comedy saw sandler as the
titular happy gilmore an outsider with a
huge tax bill to pay and a knack for the
sport of golf he proves his medal at a
small tournament earning an entry into a
professional tour that has enough prize
money to settle his financial burden as
happy continues barreling towards the
title of champion another professional
player shooter mcgavin is less than
pleased to see a total newbie play at
his level mcgavin becomes determined to
throw gilmore off by any means necessary
hiring people to harass him and even
trying to flat out buy his competitor
out of the sport for good despite the
temptation gilmore pushes through
determined to beat mcgavin in his own
game and ultimately win the title of
champion from the egotistical and
childish mcgavin
you'd think a film with a lead that
sounds ready to cut a summer camp full
of teens to bids but have its titular
character be the biggest baddie but
those who have watched this tim burton
classic know better than that while the
titular scissorhands is nothing but kind
hearted toward those around him even
falling in love with the girl he lives
with named kim her boyfriend jim is
nothing but nasty to edward jim
repeatedly tries to turn the people in
town against edward first setting him up
to get arrested during a burglary and
then startling him into cutting kim with
his hands after kim breaks up with jim
as a result of his constant harassment
things take a turn for the worse as jim
vows to get his revenge on edward in the
final confrontation at edward's old
mansion jim's true colors are revealed
when he slaps kim across the face
causing edward to finally snap and stab
jim to death and not a moment too soon
sure for most of his time at hogwarts
draco malfoy was nothing but a constant
thorn in the side of harry and pretty
much everyone else who he interacts with
but he's a kid so he gets a pass on at
least a few things the cat loving and
sickeningly pink dolores umbridge on the
other hand doesn't get any forgiveness
from us her smug self-righteous attitude
only does more harm than good as she
rises to become the headmistress of
hogwarts during harry's fifth year
during her reign she was unusually harsh
and acting strict punishments on
students left and right a prime example
of which is when she tortured harry by
forcing him to write an apology into his
own flesh to make matters even worse she
weakened the entire student body by
crippling their study of defense against
the dark arts helping to set up the
disasters that would soon befall the
school her snooty controlling and
unbelievably cruel attitude only made it
that much more satisfying watching her
get dragged into the woods by centaurs
before he would direct ferris bueller's
day off john hughes would create weird
science an oddball teen comedy that
starred the socially awkward gary and
wyatt the friend duo decides to create a
real woman named lisa frankenstein style
always nearby is wyatt's domineering
older brother chet whose sole purpose in
life is to make wyatt's life a living
hell while lisa's purpose is to look
over the two boys she can't prevent much
of chet's harassment towards the duo not
yet at least
between his constant extortion of his
younger brother name-calling and
comically violent behavior it's no
wonder the two leads try to hide their
supernatural creation from chet things
come to a head when he busts down a door
and sticks a shotgun in gary's face
after chet forces gary and wyatt out of
the house with their girlfriends in hand
lisa decides enough is enough and turns
his tyrannical nutcase into a giant
disgusting blob monster
you could say someone's true colors only
show when they're put into a stressful
situation and that couldn't be more true
when your stressor is a mysterious and
thick mist that no one returns from
adapted from a stephen king novella of
the same name the pass of people of a
small town converge on a small
supermarket in this 2007 horror film
from there things turn even more bizarre
as hordes of creatures assault the small
building and its occupants in your
typical horror movie fair the cohesion
of the group is put to the test
ultimately winding up being a worse slot
than the giant bugs that they're trying
to fend off one particularly wicked
member of the bunch mrs carmody views
the whole situation as the wrath of god
whipping her followers into a cult-like
fervor and leading them into committing
human sacrifice and the movie only gets
more brutal from there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]